certainly here in Washington people
didn't see this one coming today this
relates to 2017 it's come from Julian
Assange his lawyer who has essentially
said that through this former Republican
congressman Donna Rohrabacher Donald
Trump offered Julian Assange a pardon
he's wanted in the u.s. of course on 18
counts of endangering national security
related to that release of classified
information that he could have a pardon
for that if Julian Assange denied that
Russia had any involvement in the
hacking of those DNA National Committee
emails in the run-up to the 2016
election now those emails were I think
at worst embarrassing for the Democrats
some of the detail had them undermining
Bernie Sanders who was of course running
against Hillary Clinton at the time but
it was a very big moment that was
certainly perceived as potentially
damaging in the run-up to the election
now one of the very interesting things
here is that Julian Assange did just
that
remember he went on Fox News at the time
and spoke to Sean Hannity's effectively
an advisor to Donald Trump and said that
the Russian government was not the
source that gave them those emails
because the allegation is of course that
Russia hacked the emails and WikiLeaks
actually leaked them so he did that so
you know if this is all true then where
is Julian Assange is pardoned so what
the Democrats and Trump's critics will
say here this is proof that Donald Trump
was working with the Russians in the
run-up to the 2016 election of course
the investigation into all that the
Special Counsel investigation ultimately
said no there may have been associations
between the Russians and Trump
associates there may have been meetings
but there was no conspiracy between them
now we have a statement from the White
House re to you quickly the president
barely knows down a Rohrabacher other
than he's an ex congressman he's never
spoken to him on this subject or almost
any subject it is complete fabrication
and a total lie this is probably another
never-ending hoax and a total lie from
the DNC that's the Democratic National
Committee but you get the sense from
Julian Assange his lawyer that they plan
to back this out with some evidence
you